hey guys to this Tuesday today my name
is Chad Andhra and you're watching games
what news here's the things that
mattered in gaming today
[Music]
first up grand theft auto 5 is now the
best-selling video game in the u.s. of
all time ever been it thanks it during a
financial briefing today take to
revealed that GTA 5 is quote the
all-time best-selling video game both in
revenues and units based on combined us
digital and physical sales across PC
console and portable with 85 million
units sold the previous record-holder
was we bought which sold eighty two
point eight three million units
worldwide so good job Rockstar also in
the report it was revealed that micro
transaction revenue has grown 66% a
year-on-year and accounted for a
whopping forty eight percent of total
net revenue it looks like games of the
service are here to stay I hadn't spent
money on a game ever
for the initial spend of my you nobody
else a no um which I've been told is a
bad thing before I buy expansion packs
from time to time where does the when is
the line end for an expansion pack today
you'll see these days is getting pretty
pretty hefty go frozen wild horizon yeah
you've got all the stuff for the
assassin screens usually have like cool
story and people stuff like that I think
like and I don't necessarily feel like I
need a certain amount of hours to get
out of it to justify my spend but I do
kind of feel like if I feel like I'm
getting a meaty experience that I really
want then it does make sense that if
just say you know you can't afford a lot
of games you get GTA online and they're
constantly giving you new stuff to do
and then when you do get a little bit of
money you want to spend it on you know
the game that you've already put so many
hours into I mean it it totally makes
sense have I spent money in GTA online
yes I have Rainbow six siege she's one
of my favorite games and I bought charms
I've bought season passes I've bought
operators I'm bought it all it's great
most of what loot boxes in our watch
because got to get that shirtless McCrae
unfortunately now it's time for some sad
news telltale games in the developers of
The Walking Dead Dan tales from the
borderlands has laid off 90 employees
these layoffs are a part of a
comprehensive company restructuring and
impact all divisions all of those 90
people make up 25% of telltale stop a
press release indicates that the move
will make the company quote more
competitive as a developer and publisher
of groundbreaking story driven gaming
variances with an emphasis on high
quality in the years ahead
telltale added that the projects it has
announced won't be affected the studio
added that they intend to finally
address the long-standing fan concern
that the developer relies heavily on
aging technology
oh man that's such good news our
thoughts go out to those affected by the
layoffs and we do hope you land on your
feet Xenoblade Chronicles 2 it's almost
out on switch and today Nintendo
announced its plans to support the game
post launch there some good stuff in
there as its 2017 and loot boxes have
only just come into vogue Xenoblade
Chronicles 2 will be supported post
launch with new story content new quests
and a new blade and if you're a Japanese
game purist you'll be stoked to hear
that a free day one patch will add in an
optional Japanese audio track pretty
sweet you can grab the DLC in the $30.00
season pass for which you'll get bonus
support items when Xenoblade Chronicles
2 launches in December and you quest in
January 2018 the aforementioned rare
blade in spring a challenge mode
sometime next summer and new story
content next fall
no International pricing has been
announced about several bundles with the
season pass have crept up in the various
regional each shops with the game in
season pass going for 77 pounds in the
UK and a whopping 134 dollars 95 here in
Australia there will also be new free
breath of the wild DLC senator and
Xenoblade Chronicles 2 which will
include a side quest that once completed
will unlock a costume but based on
xenoblade's rex Sena play Chronicles 2
is out on intend dose which on December
1st that is everything we got for you
today do let us know what you thought of
today's story it's in that comment box
and you know yes 33 games to it there's
not thanks for bringing that up what
there is there is the heir announcement
that we're doing extra life on November
17th the whole game sports doing it for
72 hours you can watch this all play
games and get delirious from a lack of
sleep and too many pixels into eyeballs
it's gonna be great yes Australia's
doing the last leg as always so you can
join us for the last 24 hours we'll make
sure you have all the information
beforehand but um yeah should be chill
what else is going on Dan how much
missus will see you guys tomorrow all
right first up grand theft auto 5 is not
the best-selling video game in the u.s.
of all time ever babe thanks dad
today has me doing car noises